and isn't it somebody's job to make sure
that this person is dead and declared
dead what do they call them what's the
number for like the Executioner yeah
okay it's just execution
you dead you guys dead I think it's one
step before that don't you dare fake it
I'm gonna declare you dead unless you
speak up
[Music]
we kind of talked about this earlier too
but Singapore hangs its second citizen
in three weeks for trafficking cannabis
despite calls to Halt execute bro you
just gotta stop bringing drugs into
Singapore please God damn it dude
they're not playing yeah how many times
dude just don't even think about it just
stop trying yeah it's kind of that's
where was the person from
don't say Malaysia because that's
usually what's [__] happening right
does it say what what month they're born
well this was a 37 year old man who got
executed uh after his last ditch bid to
reopen his case was dismissed by court
Tuesday he was not named as his family
as privacy but had been in prison for
seven years and convicted in 2019 for
trafficking around 1.5 kilos or 3.3
pounds of cannabis don't do that just
stop bringing that [__] in basically the
court rejected it
three pounds yeah under Singapore laws
trafficking more than 500 grams or 1.1
pounds of cannabis may result in the
death penalty just do a little bit less
than that they're gonna kill that one
dude who was like I had a proven IQ of
like a baby remember that and he was
manipulated they manipulate this guy to
be a mule and he brought drugs in and
then uh all these celebrities were
pleading to Singapore to not kill him
because he doesn't know what he did and
they did it anyway
tweeted it with
but do it yeah I saw Richard Branson
posting about it right yeah don't do it
Richard brentz is asking like all these
people are playing this is the dirty guy
right dirty the leader no that's
Philippines but they'll kill you for
just having drugs in general but at the
airport they can they can kill you on
the spot right I mean it seems that
these people are being tried still but
um some 60 prisoners on a death row in
the city-state mostly for drug-related
offenses right now offenses right now
Singapore executed 11 people last year
for drug offenses after a two-year
Hiatus due to kovid the hanging in one
particular Malaysian believes to be
mentally disabled sparked that
International outcry yeah if you want to
sell drugs just come over here just find
another Market man that's crazy even
though it was only when I first went in
like
2007 the first thing I saw when I got
off the plane were the signs showing you
like it's like a it was like a
silhouette of a dude with a rifle on a
kneeling guy and it said like capital
punishment for all drug related offenses
yeah they don't play dude yeah you know
how people like moved to LA to pursue
acting like you should move here to
pursue drug selling instead of yeah man
yeah very popular area for the drugs way
safer here
and it's like dude you can make friends
it's peaceful you go to Singapore you
could indulge in sex tourism oh wait
that was with uh Walter you're talking
about
but yeah that's a you could do a lot of
stuff in Singapore is it sexy times
legal there I think it is I think it's
sexuals in there yeah dude the sexy
times in Singapore and sell the drugs
over here yeah dude
you can't have it all in one place okay
you guys dude I remember when it's
Singapore it was the cleanest city I've
ever been to there's not one piece of
gum on the floor I got yelled at for
drinking water dude I got yelled at on
the street are you crazy not on the
street but it was it was a mall slash uh
train station and I was like chilling
right in between and I was drinking a
bottle of water and this Old Uncle were
you walking no I was chilling I was
waiting for my mom and you can't drink
water in public well I was in the train
station there's no drinking water on the
train station yeah it makes a mess and
then the old Uncle who was in the
security office like a outfit he came up
to me and was like we have cameras
everywhere we saw you drink water you
can't be drinking water in here and just
lecturing me he's I'll give you a ticket
next time you do that and I was like
sorry bro [__] so I bottled it up and I
just put it away wow and that was over a
bottle of water the whip the Whip you
for spitting gum on the or spitting on
the floor or something that's kind of
cool that's why it's so clean but that's
why they have those ones you'll go to
jail for getting in a fight
so literally it says ah [__] what was
the wording it has like there's also
signs that are talking about like uh
there's something to do with like don't
regret like one night for like 30 years
wanna spend the night start a fight
there was an initiative the first the
first time I was there there was like a
a nationwide campaign to smile more and
to say hello because
um there was I guess there's a thing in
Singapore back then where people were so
shy that tourists like it was not a good
experience so they wanted to promote
like saying hello asking if you need
help fighting something uh if someone
asks you what the time is like answer
them it's like people always shy away
they are pretty helpful these days yeah
yeah it's pretty cool that they did that
but it's cool they could just change the
culture of like the citizen like that
yeah I guess because it's one of those
things where they're like hey if you
want tourism to pick up we need money to
come in so be nicer to people you could
also drive across the whole island in
like 30 minutes
smaller than L.A County I'm just saying
it's easier it's easier to manage like a
body of people when it's like the
conditions are more convenient yeah yeah
now did they change change that because
they talk to them or because there was a
consequence if you didn't like smile or
die I think it really wasn't about
yourself real quick the tone is a little
different there I think it's one of
those things where the culture just
understands that they're in it together
it's not like here where everyone's like
nah [__] that like there they were like
oh you know we want this result let's
get it together that's crazy it reminds
me of Japan everybody's all unified
together yeah it's kind of crazy plus
it's like when people criticize
Singapore and they'd be like look at all
the inhumane like uh consequences for
all this [__] it's like you can't talk
[__] on a country the size of this
County that is making that much success
honestly they're probably doing it right
hate to say it but it's like it must be
going well yeah it's like have you
licked the sidewalk
it's clean it's just the fact that
children can hang out at 2 A.M and
there's no like fear that something is
gonna happen dude we saw some kids hop
off the bus and then we started walking
around yeah they're like like eight
years old just walking by themselves
yeah all right bye and they walk home
you can't you don't see that over here
so dope I love it three weeks ago uh the
Singaporean was actually hanged for in
the first execution of this year for
trafficking one kilogram or 2.2 pounds
of cannabis although he was not caught
with the drugs prosecutor said phone
numbers traced him as the person
responsible for coordinating the
delivery
so I imagine you're not even like
touching it or you're just coordinating
the delivery you get caught you're hung
you're just an accomplice when we were
there in 2019 the bus the cab driver was
telling us about how
um like weed is pretty popular over
there but so is ice that's like the main
drug over there is that synthetic I
don't even know what that means ice yeah
like frozen water cocaine is that is
that okay do you think uh celebrities
since you like know a lot or like the
Asian celebrities do you think they're
Above the Law over there not in China or
like in Singapore in Singapore that's
what the cab driver was saying he was
like all the politicians do that [__]
because I know I knew because like a lot
of like uh like Korean Korea is Pretty
Tough too but then a lot of like Korean
celebrities are like they can operate
Above the Law and it's easy for them to
get weed and do all that stuff so I was
wondering like if it's like if you're an
Asian pop star if you even when you get
to Singapore you're like okay we better
[__] be careful or can they operate
Above the Law I'm sure they're probably
above law they probably have more to
lose though so they probably actually
stay away for real for real oh but it's
all about appearances so I mean as long
as you're not seen doing it that's why
they'd be drinking heavy and smoking
cigarettes like days you know like all
day but when it comes to something that
is like within the legal parameter of
being like this is wrong then I feel
like they stay away up more often but
yeah I'd rather not die it's a flex too
when like let's say that you're you're
like at a level in in uh the Emirates
let's say you're like a person that
lives in the Emirates like Dubai and
you're at that level where you're above
the law if you have visitors come in
it's a flex to give them those same
things that you do to be like hey you
wanna you wanna go get girls you want to
go get drugs like it's a flex to extend
that yeah so it's like probably works
like that in Singapore too hey yo
look at you with your Dubai Flags just
selling out all my insiders
apart from Singapore Amnesty
International said Indonesia carried out
112 drug-related executions last year by
firing squad after Hiatus since 2016. in
contrast neighboring Thailand has
legalized cannabis while Malaysia has
ended the mandatory death penalty for
serious crimes if you survive a firing
squad do they shoot you a second time
you become president or do you like do
you like uh they're just gonna keep
shooting that's not fair until you drop
it can't just be like okay everyone here
gets the culture at one time and then
like if you like if they're like right
when they shoot they get into like a
weird stance and you somehow don't get
hit they should be able to survive and
like I like that rule actually because
then it's okay God wanted me to live
take matters in your own hands you know
right because that's [__] up everyone
gets to like shoot you and then every
time you keep moving yeah and they get
to shoot you 10 more times but
murdered somebody by shooting them like
a hundred times and then you're like oh
you guys only get one bullet yeah so 50
Cent if he got shot seven times in
Singapore he would have died because
they would have kept shooting yeah they
want to stop at Seven it's like oh I
made it I made it damn man because 50
Cent got shot seven different times
right was that I think one time one time
seven yeah one time and one in one
incident really but then all that once I
thought it was seven times one time
his attitude dude after like the six
would be like oh God damn come on he's
like I'm Invincible yeah dude why
doesn't anyone like me seven different
guys one time same spot because yeah if
you get the electric chair like let's
say uh right and then the okay this
guy's dead so the tip carry on on a
stretcher
and then they're like wait I'm alive
dude they go let's bring them back yeah
yeah do-over yeah I don't think they're
like congratulations walk on home but I
think they yeah I think they quietly
just kill you shake them a bun
hello
you got a brand new car and isn't it
somebody's job to make sure that this
person is dead and declared dead what do
they call them what's the name like the
Executioner yeah okay it's just the
Executioner the corner just make it you
dead you guys dead I mean I think it's
one step before that don't you dare
[__] fake it I'm gonna declare you
dead unless you speak up
speak now or you're fighting yeah I
think chopping heads off is more um
theatrical bring back the guillotes it's
more more what's the word like oh like
he's dead for sure more guaranteed yeah
more Guillotine it is it is kind of
funny that like oh imagine the blade
gets stuck out way to the neck though
[Applause]
everybody's pushing on it hey put your
weight on it here it Go step get on my
back is [__] up hook it up man now you
need one swing rule you need to battle
ax one swing it is it is so strange that
like we keep eliminating methods of of
uh capital punishment because of
inhumanity yet like the ones that are
left over you can still look scrutinize
and go that's inhumane now to the new
standard dude killing someone is
inhumane yeah
but so are the people [__] so are the
crimes right yeah bro come on
[Music]